G1
[Música]
e
você sabe que a música clássica e quais
corpos a representa façamos o seguinte
exercício trás por alguns instantes dos
seus olhos imagina que você ganhou o
ingresso para assistir a um concerto
colocou aquela roupa super maneira
talvez elegante e agora você tá lá
sentada no seu lugarzinho marcado
pe Meu Deus Que barulho é esse Sim este
é o primeiro sinal
e naquela poltrona da qual não se sabe
se é barulhenta mas que poderá a
qualquer instante vão ver todo o
silêncio do espetáculo você observa as
pessoas ao seu redor que pensaram com
vocês e tiraram a roupa elegante e
dentro do guarda-roupa Be agora você
sabe o que que é segundo se não
sentir um pouquinho de tensão lá para um
possível ataque de tosses entre os
movimentos ou applaudir na hora errada
be terceiro sinal o conceito está para
começar E você tá lá e imaginando o teu
músculo saindo da coxinha se
movimentando até o pau ele não faz desde
que você está lá para observá-lo agora
tem que ser o barulho dos Passos
e ele tá com seu instrumento na mão
concentrado para promover um espetáculo
belíssimo
o espetáculo com isso
você conseguiu imaginar
e olha eu não sou vidente Mas é uma
grande chance dessa pessoa na qual você
imaginou fazer parte de imaginar o
padrão corrupção
pré-estabelecidos como pertencentes
desses passos de teatro
aqueles que a gente encontra em filmes
da Sessão da Tarde de princesas com
orquestras ou em alguns comerciais
chocolate
caso você que apreciaram a musicista que
foge desse aqui é tipo que se encontra
dentro da sua imaginação
abre os teus olhos e Aprecia sobra do
violão que sim não está dentro da
orquestra e não toca Beethoven mas é
música clássica
sambalanço de Jair Teodoro de Paula a
[Música]
E aí
e agora
[Música]
nós estamos algo não tão familiar mas ao
mesmo tempo muito familiar eu vou dizer
como é que nasceu a minha relação com o
violão eu achava cômico e ao mesmo tempo
me chateava com algumas
obrigatoriedades que as pessoas colocava
ele colocam quando vem músico
Principalmente um violonista achando em
pano que se sabe a cantar conhecer todas
as músicas que são midiáticas por muito
tempo eu fugia de tocar violão clássico
para todas as pessoas que não entendiam
que eu estava aprendendo
Afinal sempre era questionada por não
saber tocar músicas ditas como comum é
porque eu fui me aprofundando no
instrumento entendi o porquê que as
pessoas esperassem que eu fizesse
malabarismos com ela
por ser um instrumento acessível
comparado a todos os outros e pela
relação que o mesmo traje cumplicidade é
muito comum você encontrar o violão
entre amigos em rodas festas de família
praças ou barzinhos juntando afinidade
do violão com comum uma mulher preta e
eu não como tocando não
mas não conhecido sobre o clássico é a
seguinte coisa sabe por quê que você
toca essas músicas instrumentais que
ninguém conhece não entende nunca nem
ouviu falar
e
a bomba caiu quando eu comecei a
observar com mais profundidade o meu
entorno voltando o exercício quando você
estava no teatro ele todo aquele pessoal
com a roupa chique havia uma pessoas
pretas
e não Palco como foi se artista do qual
você imaginou
E foi exatamente nisso que eu passei até
mais percepção todo lugar que eu
frequentava ficava procurando por esses
copos pretos e quando se tratava de
conservatório Universidade as pessoas
pretas parecendo sumir muito pelo
contrário quando eu Experience A vá
manifestações culturais e deixada de
herança da escravidão foi como estalo
comecei a entender que de fato esse
lugar poderia não me pertencer
mas tudo isso mudou quando eu vi
importância da representatividade
aquilombamento
meu primeiro Professor
preto de violão clássico o homem cujo
qual foi o primeiro professor do curso
que fundou o curso de violão clássico do
Conservatório de Tatuí o seu Jair seu
Jair me dava em suas aulas
oportunidades e brechas para que eu
pudesse observar o potencial de ir além
do que eu estava oferecendo um o sujeito
foi a pessoa que me fez ver as
possibilidades de estudos fique me
ajudou a quebrar diversas maneiras
Há muitas experiências vividas concursos
festivais viagens e o questionamento que
sempre me permeava Cadê as pessoas
pretas que não estão aqui também fazendo
música
a observar esses corpos dentro de
instituições entender os privilégios
Perdas e Ganhos Por estarem ali me
fizeram cada vez mais entender toda a
questão do racismo dentro desse
mecanismo que a gente chama de sociedade
o quanto a oportunidade para se está
distante de uma enorme parcela da
população e como isso por muito tempo
deixou o ciclo fechado para pessoas
específicas detalhe eu não tô nem
pontuando a presença da mulher preta
porque se for olhar coisa ficar mais
sinistra mas entendeu porque desse preto
agonismo não está dentro da música
clássica clássica se refere reflete
dentro do próprio espaço
imagina fui muito tempo fazer música
clássica era um que era pessoal da
realeza os burgueses aí 20 e esse é o
tipo de coisa que a gente acabou dando
dos tempos o e observando esse mundo
ocidental e todas as tendências que eles
nos oferecem a ruptura dessa tradição
acaba por vindo de alguns movimentos
sociais que muito compressão foram
necessários para fazer com que o acesso
chegasse para outros corpos onde sempre
se falou na diversidade brasileira mas a
possibilidade de entrada nunca foi para
todo mundo
projetos sociais foram e são de extrema
importância
para que esses copos possam acessar
outras formas
é de acesso
bom e até mesmo a profissionalização
Olá eu sou um exemplo desses projetos
tive acesso ao violão clássico no
Projeto Guri e me tornei uma
profissional mas não romantizando O
processo foi uma oportunidade
social
que eu pude conquistar os meus direitos
pode ainda é falho
e de fato a gente precisa discutir essa
falta de acesso a especificamente a
música clássica
nossos ancestrais trazidos de África não
tiveram escolha de vir para cá e muito
menos de sobreviver a tudo causa da
escravidão
Possivelmente a intenção não era por ali
fazer uma arte que estava toda voltada a
burguesia branca e aos bons costumes e
e mais ainda esse lugar nos pertences o
apagamento desses seres humanos
escravizados e explica por si só pro
porque de hoje temos poucos que
frequentam esses lugares é muito comum
Romantizar que é bonito ter uma duas ou
três pessoas pretas dentro de orquestras
de universidades Mas é com essa reflexão
sobre heranças espaços que trago aqui a
minha outra grande referência de
profissional
João Luiz Rezende
violonista compositor premiado com o
Grammy latino
professor em três universidades
Americanas
artista preto que vem trazendo as
diásporas pretas em suas composições e
além da sua trajetória com a música Traz
a relevância de transitar entre o estilo
informal e formal da música clássica
além as estações culturais da diáspora
africana se deixadas pelos pelos nossos
ancestrais em grande parte das suas
obras
e quando o conheci o João por meio das
suas gravações eu fiquei extremamente
contente de poder saber que um dia eu
teria a possibilidade de me tornar
alguém próximo de tudo grande o sismo
trabalho que o violonista clássico pode
conquistar
o pelo de um
Xangô de João Luiz Rezende e
[Música]
E aí
o
cocô aqui com a seguinte mensagem mesmo
que pequenas referências fazem diferença
e que se precisava pensar mais é com
dialogamos com todas financiamento dos
povos pretos dentro da nossa história a
música clássica está dentro de padrões
que quase sempre não favorecem muitos e
sim poucos o que Diverge muito do que
seria o papel da música para
sobrevivência do ser humano a troca de
culturas quando não idealizada por
poderão soberania sempre pode ser algo
que agrega muito
a minha sugestão a primeira coisa seria
enxergar que não existe cultura é melhor
do que a outra que ela se adapta
segundo. Aparência não deveria ser um
divisor de águas terceiro e último é
preciso desvencilhar alguns achamentos
que perpetuam até hoje nas nossas
tradições
muito obrigada ó
[Aplausos]